so I'm gonna do this one I don't know
exactly how you say ease sale or love in
wholesale I love this train that up yeah
really interesting company so basically
the premise is it's a marketplace for
buying and selling used smartphones and
you know I'll tell you some of their
stats I haven't sort of verified how
real these are but they say that you
smartphone sales are forty six billion
dollars a year annual market they say
that two hundred thirty million
smartphones are sold per year you could
do the math that checks out they have so
what they did is they made a marketplace
where you could if you have phones and
you're a wholesaler you can basically
say hey I'm either I'm looking to buy or
looking to sell and they made it like a
stock market you basically put a a bid
up you say I'd like to buy this iPhone
and if somebody has it they can fill
your order and they can basically like
dude they can close your transaction out
there your ticket out or you can say I'm
selling a hundred of these specific
Android phones and somebody could say
I'll buy ten of those and so they made
it easy they said that most of this used
to happen through Facebook groups
whatsapp sort of the underground you
know just using social tools but then I
wasn't a marketplace and that was
focused on this and so they they've
400,000 and gmv so far now DMV you know
you can assume maybe they're making you
know in the tens of thousand dollars
themself then the GMB gross merchandise
volume volume okay so basically how much
is total sold through their market so if
one sells for a thousand dollars that's
$1,000 of gmv their cut might be five
percent ten percent of that but this is
a because the smartphone if the
smartphone if the used smartphone
marketplace is this big and they have
some stats about how fast it's growing
they say that you smartphone sales is
growing faster than new smartphone sales
per year because you know Apple is
trying to like make the old model
irrelevant so quickly and sure some
people do upgrade but there's all these
other phones tool out there that are
still very good phones I like I I can
afford new phones I up until my most
recent phone all of them have been used
and the the best part about these guys
is so
I believe that they were bootstrapped I
don't know how much I'm sure but they so
they've gotten to this point they they
themselves for former buyers and traders
of cellphones and they had sold prior to
this just as brokers eight million
dollars over the cellphones and then
decided to create a sort of technology
marketplace out of this so if you think
about it market love it style of
business marketplace love it so I love
that love that they're going for use
market views smartphones
I love that they're doing a marketplace
I love that they came from a background
where they actually did this manually
before and we're sort of prolific
brokers eight plus plus love this love
this company here on the YC list okay I
like it let me play devil's advocate
here which is okay so I looked up a few
okay so first of all I think that this
is a lot harder than people think the
reason why I think it's a lot harder is
I think it's incredibly competitive with
a lot of people who are already very
established so I think getting
distribution and getting eyeballs on
their product is going to be
prohibitively expensive maybe I also
think that so there's a company called
swap uh do you know swap uh no but I see
your note here
okay here's why this is interesting I've
actually used it before but I didn't but
what's interesting is I posted or I have
a thread that I found of the guy who's
what's a swap ax is the same thing but
slightly different I don't know how it's
slightly different but it's the same
it's a you by youself cellphones what's
interesting is that in 2011 the guy who
started swap up posted on Hacker News
and he said hey I'm launching this thing
on the side here's what it does and so
you can actually go in like see how he
started it
and it's I don't know how big it is
right now but it's it comes up number
one when you google by you cellphones so
I would imagine it does I bet you it
does fifty million dollars in sales at
least because I'm comparing it to the
person that's number two which is
gazelle which is a big company but
anyway swap bootstraps and so I if I was
a greedy if I was these ease guys how
you say it easy yeah if I was
these guys and I or what did you say
let's go with easy if I was easy I would
be greedy and wanna raise very little
money like less than a million dollars
and just see how well how I can just
make this really profitable but you know
they say launch three months ago 400 kg
MV monthly I'm at 8 percent margin
profitable and growing a 20 percent
month-over-month of course easy to be
profitable when you have two people
you're not taking salaries but
nonetheless I think this could be a
profitable business because of the you
know the sort of take rate
[Music]